kindle chicla v med spa the sponsors of
this next segment has a new team member
adding more services and experience to
their menu check it out
hi i'm erica kimball i'm a nurse
practitioner at chic livy med spa here
at smith plastic surgery i come with 14
years experience in dermatology that's
where i started so i have a unique
experience of learning skin from
basically the bottom up how it reacts to
different procedures and even
medications to give for any adverse
events that would happen
as i fell in love with the industry of
dermatology i also started to expand my
services to anti-aging and wellness and
really started getting into more media i
am a health and beauty author for
different magazines i've been featured
on different television media sources
i've kind of brought some of the history
of being in pageants as being miss las
vegas class like 2015 also into the
beauty world now here at chicla v and
bringing in a whole new list of services
for our menu we'll have things like co2
laser which is great for resurfacing of
the skin especially after having like a
facelift because you have this saggy
skin that was kind of pulled back but
you haven't changed the tone or texture
of the skin and that you want to
definitely
establish better skin afterwards
also bringing pdo threads which is an
alternative to having something like a
facelift it's where we insert thread
that's almost like a suture into the
skin as little barbs on it and it helps
to pull the skin back but without having
surgery other procedures that we're
bringing in to help to keep you healthy
and youthful after
many of the procedures at smith plastic
surgery would be like our bioidentical
hormones so we're not doing synthetic
hormones we're actually doing
bioidenticals which are made from
typically like yam root or something
very natural and it helps you as you get
older and going into andropause
menopause to kind of keep the levels
that you had closer to age 30 so that
you can keep your metabolism up your
clarity of mind you can help with sleep
you can help to have more muscle tone
and less fat as you get older and keep
stability of emotions as well
also medical weight loss which goes very
well with some of the procedures we do
here so after having something like a
tummy tuck or a liposuction how do you
keep the weight off afterwards so you
besides diet and exercise you do want to
be in something like maybe medical
weight loss beforehand and then
bioidenticals after we're catering more
to males as well so some of the peptides
that you can do along with bioidentical
hormone therapy to gain a little muscle
if you come in for your typical
injectables and you have acne we'll
treat it here as well to make it
convenient to you
as well as things like skin tag removal
or cosmetic mold removal we want to have
it all under one roof i'd also like to
make an offer to you of something new
that we have on board called quo which
helps to get rid of cellulite in the
thigh and buttock area we're going to
give away like buy one get one free for
the first five callers to schedule for a
quo treatment
pick up those phones thank you to chica
v med spa for sponsoring this segment
visit their chiclevi med spa on sahara
boulevard and for more information just
call 702-233-8535